CDC is warning about Salmonella in
Turkey just days before Thanksgiving 164
people in 35 states report getting sick
after eating turkey 63 were hospitalized
and one died one case resulted in the
voluntary recall of more than 91
thousand pounds of jennie-o brand ground
turkey but other brands are an unsafe
preparation are also believed to be
linked to the outbreak our dr. Tara
Narula is here with more cetera we all
want to be safe this Thanksgiving what
do we know about this recent outbreak
well the outbreak has been going on for
about a year so it's not something
that's new but the recall does just
apply to that one lot of jennie-o ground
turkey but in general we think this is
more widespread they found the
Salmonella strain in different brands
different types of turkey different
stores so it's important to be careful
when handling your whole turkey this
Thanksgiving but the CDC is saying do
not avoid eating turkey you just need to
know how to properly handle it and
prepare it so what are some of the
symptoms of salmonella if in fact you
think that you are contaminated so
salmonella is responsible for about a
million causes of food poisoning every
year and basically when you ingest the
bacteria about 12 to 72 hours later you
can develop nausea vomiting diarrhea
fever stomach cramps it's typically
self-limited so it resolves within 4 to
7 days in most people but in some people
it can get into the bloodstream it can
become a little more serious more
serious diarrhea requiring
hospitalization rarely death and people
who are more vulnerable seem to be young
less than 5 years old older a greater
than 65 and those who are
immunocompromised ifferent than most
people cook a regular like Butterball
turkey but so does that apply to those
kind of turkeys too it applies to all
turn I mean they're still really
investigating and trying to figure out
they have not been able to identify a
single source or supplier of the raw
turkey or live turkeys yeah bottom line
if you cook your turkey correctly you
won't get salmonella
if you cook and prepare correctly so
they do recommend certain things like
don't thaw your turkey on the counter
because if it goes the temperature goes
above 40 degrees Fahrenheit that's the
danger zone so you want to thaw it in
the fridge don't wash your poultry a lot
of people make this mistake because
those water droplets can splatter and
spread and contaminate surfaces make
sure to be good about washing your hands
with warm soapy water for 20 seconds
clean
you're cutting boards and not cutting
salad or fruits on those same cutting
boards and then don't cook your stuffing
inside the turkey because that can
absorb those juices and but get a
thermometer always has to be over 175
yes yes I mean all the things you said
not to do my mom would do we put it on
because I don't know how to cook but we
put it on the counter butter it up yeah
wash it first now cook the dressing
inside the turkey all the things you
said cause the wind runs too low
some people even wear gloves when
they're handling the turkey oh yeah I
mean the more careful you are the better
and really that's what this is about I
mean Salmonella can happen to anyone
anywhere it's it's you know in the
poultry industry so if you know how to
prepare it and handle it the right way
you should be fine you'll justified the
odds then yeah chef Jeff's wears gloves
if you need something she knows how to
cook and so does her husband they don't
call him chef for nothing